so one of the things I've been talking
to my audiences about is the
relationship between responsibilities
and meaning you're doing it again stop
it
it's a limiting belief and let me tell
you how good life becomes when you take
on responsibility it gets real good rise
and shine it's an espresso time what's
up belief nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message take responsibility over to you
Jordan Peterson also if you want to know
what Jordan Peterson and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in description below if
you're gonna speak effectively you have
to know way more than you're talking
about so one of the things I've been
talking to my audiences about is the
relationship between responsibility and
meaning which is there and what would
you say it's a it's a constant refrain
in the book it's one of its underlying
messages let's say or themes is a better
way of thinking about it
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that it and and they have the reasons
but you need something to put up against
that and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that
katastrophe and most of that meaning is
to be found in the adoption of
responsibility so if you think for
example if you think about the people
that you admire well you think about
when you have a clear conscience first
because that's a good thing to aim at
which is something different than
happiness right a clear conscience is
different than happiness yeah it's
better yeah
that's not you're guilting yourself
you're not feeling bad about your sister
right you feel that you've just a claim
you've justified your existence right
and so you're not waking up at 3 in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you should have said I you
acted or what opportunity you lost or or
or yeah or or the things that you've
that you've let go that you should have
capitalized on and all of that and so if
you think about the times when you're at
peace with yourself with regards to how
you're conducting yourself in the world
it's almost always conditions under
which you've adopted responsibility
right at least the most the most guilt I
think that you can experience perhaps is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and I unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not not only are you not
taking care of yourself let's say so
someone else has to but you're not
living up to your full potential and so
there's a existential weight that goes
along with that it's not your mom's
fault it's yours when things aren't
going our way when you're not getting
the results that you want we love
blaming other people right we love
blaming the economy we love blaming our
customers we love blaming the government
we love blooming the president
we love blaming our parents we love to
blame blame blame blame blame blame
blame and the truth is when you blame
somebody else it feels great it does it
feels great to be able to blame somebody
else that's not your fault
it's not your responsibility it's that
person's fault it's your parents fault
they messed you up it's their fault that
you're in the situation that you're in
right now right it feels great to be
able to put the blame on them let me
you have to do anything and that means
you lose your power means you lose your
power
it means you lose your ability to
control your situation as long as you
have somebody else to blame it means you
don't have to take any kind of action
it's only when you stand up and you say
this is my responsibility I'm in charge
of my life I'm an adult now I get to
make my own decisions I get to control
the future destiny for myself that the
past does not equal the future
that the course can change because I
will make it change because I am in
control I'm in charge it's my
responsibility to go after what I want
in life when you make that decision
first off it sucks because you realize
holy crap I have a lot of work to do
right I can't rely on anybody else to
solve this for me it's not their fault
it's mine that sucks but - it's amazing
it's the best because now you have hope
because now you know that if you make
some changes things are gonna get better
that you actually have control instead
of the alternative where you just blame
other people sit on the couch and hate
your life now I think one of the hardest
parts of this is recognizing it is being
conscious of it I think we blame and
complained by default I think when
something doesn't go our way we don't
take responsibility by default and so as
much as we'd like to where we're
hardwired or at least we've been
conditioned to blame other people and
get upset about it so I'm gonna give you
three tools that you can use to help
shift it so that you're not
automatically reacting to things in a
blaming negative way and you could
proactively claim your power claim your
responsibility and start to make a
positive change for yourself technique
number one is take the mirror test this
is really powerful this is when you walk
up to the mirror you go to your bathroom
you go to your kitchen kitchen to the
HEPA mirror you go to your bathroom
bathroom you go to your front hall
wherever there's a mirror really you go
to your mirror and you ask yourself
here's the mirror test why am I not more
successful why have I not hit my goals
you you look yourself dead in the eye
and you ask yourself why have I not
accomplished my goals and see what the
first reaction is back what's the first
thought that pops into your head and
then what's the second and what's the
third and going with a notepad or going
with your phone and load up a and write
down what comes to mind
the only acceptable answer is going to
be it's my responsibility because of me
because I'm not putting in the work yet
because I'm not trying hard enough
because I haven't invested in myself
enough yet those are acceptable answers
but they likely won't be the default
answers something's gonna come up you're
gonna blame something you're gonna blame
your circumstances you're gonna blame
your environment you're gonna blame
somebody in your life that's why the
mirror test is so powerful because when
you ask that question and you listen
right away not what you wish you
answered but what you actually answered
the things that come back in your head
those thoughts are what are going
through your head constantly you're not
paying attention to that's your
subconscious that's your default mode
all those complaining and blaming is up
there as default and so taking the
mirror test helps expose them to you so
at least you know hmm okay this is what
I'm actually thinking that's a problem
blaming my environment that's a problem
and then what it allows you to do is
take proactive action right this is my
problem so I am going to combat this I'm
gonna make an immediate change I'm gonna
change my environment and they're
stopping my parents I'm gonna make
forward progress
today and anytime I feel that thought
coming on I'm gonna kill it and I'm
gonna tell the people around me if you
ever hear me blaming my environment or
blaming my parents or whatever it is for
you you need to call me out on that you
need to you need to punch me in the
stomach you need to step on my toe you
need to you need to pull a hair out and
say you're doing it again stop it it's a
limiting belief by taking the mirror
test is super powerful technique number
two is choose education over
entertainment so when you're consuming
content whether that's a YouTube video
whether it's Netflix whether it's
magazine whether it's your phone Twitter
whatever you're consuming you have two
options it's entertainment or it's
education either laughing and
distracting yourself or you're learning
something and too often people live in
the entertainment zone and there's
nothing wrong with entertainment it's
amazing I love it
I love watching the League of Legends
worlds finals but you want education to
prioritize over entertainment so for
most people they come home they hate
their life and so they sit down and
watch a couple hours of Netflix and they
binge watch their shows and then they go
to bed and what you're doing is what
happens that scenario what you're doing
is you are running away from a life that
you don't like you are shutting off your
life and saying my life sucks
but instead of trying to tilt them to
fix it I'm gonna go watch something else
I'm gonna watch a show that makes me
laugh and forget about my problems or
I'm gonna watch a show where people's
lives are worse than mine and I'm gonna
realize that wow their life sucks even
harder than mine does you're gonna shut
off your world and go somewhere else but
the problem is you still have to live in
your world you got to wake up the next
day and go do all that all over again
when you choose education what's
happening is your gaming tools to build
a better life for yourself it's why I
made this channel it's why I want to
surround myself myself I use it for me
and I'll share with you guys with super
successful people because I want to
learn from them because they say
something the way they think the way
they see the world they drop a knowledge
bomb on me and that makes me think and
that makes me apply something to my life
to make it better so if you're unhappy
with your life if you're choosing
entertainment you're not making your
life any better you're just kind of
shutting it off for a while if you
choose education it's harder I mean
you're gonna have to work but it's
giving you the tools to actually build a
better life for yourself to take
responsibility for the life that you're
in right now the situation that you are
in right now and to actually go off and
create something better so evaluate your
day look at how you're spending your
time and see do a real audit a real
honest audit how many hours are you
spending in the land of entertainment
versus the land of Education and
technique number three to take
responsibilities to schedule for success
so look at your calendar your actions
have to map to your ambitions what you
say you want out of life has to be in
your habits has to be in your schedule
if you want to accomplish this great
thing in life you want to build this
business you want this relationship you
want this kind of level of financial
success or or fitness goals you have
goals for your life you you want to be a
certain way you want to achieve certain
results amazing I love it you have high
ambitions for yourself it's amazing most
people they have those goals for
themselves but then they're not taking
the action so it has to go to your
calendar look at your calendar look at
where you are spending your time look at
the blocks of time that are in your
calendar and you need to ask yourself on
a regular basis every week you look at
your calendar and say if I did these
actions this week where I get closer to
achieving my goals
if you want to be healthy well there
better be some workout time in your week
if not you're knocking you're never
gonna get there it's just a wish it's
just an ambition just a dream but you're
never taking steps towards it if you
want to be an entrepreneur but you're in
a 95 job great are you coming home and
working every day do you have half an
hour to three hours every night working
on your business if not then you're not
gonna cheap your goal so if you know
what your ambitions are I think this is
where a lot of people fall down they go
to an event to go there's someone
already got motivated like yes this one
I want to do this I don't do that no one
I'm gonna launch my film and I want to
write my book and I wanna I want to do
all this stuff awesome an you get so
motivate and pumped up by it but then it
never happens and then next year it's
still the same goals all over again
because you didn't take the action
because not your calendar you need to
schedule for success so go take out your
weekly calendar and look at where you
are spending your time and factor in
your work if you have a job in factoring
your family in fact you're in the
personal stuff that you have to do as
well
awesome you have to make sure that
you're making time for the activities
that are leading towards your ambitions
because you could talk a big game but if
you're not doing if it's not in your
calendar it's never gonna happen you
need to schedule for success so you can
take the mirror test you can choose
education over entertainment and you can
schedule for success it's all about
taking responsibility it's about
recognizing that I don't want to
complain anymore I don't want to just
sit on my couch hating my life and
blaming the world that is my time it's
my time to change my circumstances my
time to change where I am in life
because I don't want to be in the same
spot three years from today that I am
now the difference between you and that
person that will be three years from now
you it's how much action you've taken
not how much complaining you've done and
so I hope those techniques work I've got
a really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know when
you took the mirror test when you looked
in the mirror and you said why am I not
more successful what were the first
three thoughts that came to mind I want
to know put it down the comments below
trying to think of how to stop the loop
of my sacrifices have been rejected and
and the way that you stop that loop is
instead of saying this my sacrifices
were rejected so my hard work my effort
my everything that I'm doing to try and
move forward it's not working and and if
you want to go towards hell you keep
saying well it's it's not working but
it's but it's because of everyone else
it's they're rejecting me they're not
accepting what I've done whereas if you
say to yourself oh it didn't work okay
it's my fault what can I do better and
that's how you start moving in the other
direction
the reason I say the thing that if
there's anybody that ever looked like
you that made it then there's no excuse
is because I believe it you know it's
really hard you're in our argument and
that your friend tells you that's great
Gary but both my parents were alcoholics
and that really to me up right now
you're on the defense that's a good
first punch by them I'm like cool we
don't need to use me if anybody has ever
been successful that had two alcoholic
parents which by the way I know of three
well then now what's your Excuse Karen
we are just so interested in blaming
everybody else and excuses because we
don't want to take on responsibility and
somewhere a long time ago I went
completely I only take I do you know I
think everything is my fault like all of
it like I think it's weirdly cloudy
outside right now and not nice out my
fault like his scarred my fault
like I just default into my fault and
everybody tries to do everything else
the other way and let me tell you how
good life becomes when you take on
responsibility it gets real good uh some
of you and there's a lot of you that
follow me you know why I keep bringing
up the last scene of eight mile the
Eminem movie how many people have seen
that movie great the last scene they go
into the battle he makes fun of himself
the whole time because it leaves the
other person with nothing the leverage
is in being accountable of everything
the leverage is expose
using your weaknesses I proudly talk
about passing on uber twice being a DNF
student you know I proudly talk about my
shortcomings right
I can't wait for more bad things to
happen I mean it because I will talk
about them because what you're so
imperfect
thank you if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would become
like a little beacon if you want more
Jordan Peterson check out the top 50
rules for success video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong that you could stop doing